es geht kannst du dir auch sparen auf
diese weltverbesserung los
die schuhe kaufen möchtest ich bin nicht
egoistisch dieses eine mal kann ich doch
schwarzfahren 30 zusammen verletzt dafür
kommt wohl jemand ein schlechtes
gewissen
nee jetzt machte sie nach deswegen das
nachstellen gibt habe ich auch sie hat
auf
ich meine was macht das schon dieses
eine mal schwarzfahren die strafe solle
auch schon 60 euro kosten
das wäre mein neues paar schuhe weg
einfach so aber es erwischte kaida
dann nimmt die badezeit weniger ein mir
egal obwohl wenn jetzt keiner mehr
schwarz fahren würde sind denn die
tickets ja auch günstiger oder ich
meinen sie würden mehr geld einnehmen
und könnten dadurch die preise
zurückschrauben
dass ein kontrolleur nein ich trage
keine uniformen ich tue einfach so als
ob ich schlafen würde
es ist eine bahnfahrt uniform seine
handtaschen verdächtig aus witzige zeit
männer mit handtaschen wird nur noch
katzen mit aus seine tochter wie sie ist
die findet bestimmt cool dass ihr papa
bahnfahrer hatte mal könnte jetzt seine
arbeit verlieren
ich meine ich bin ja nicht die einzige
schwarze ringe und mein papa keinen job
mehr hat dann bekommt sie auch keine
weihnachtsgeschenke mehr und reichlich
zusammen
oh gott ich bin eine gesetzte sprecherin
eine schwarzfahrerin am rande der
gesellschaft der erste schritt in ein
kriminelles leben
als nächstes gehe ich zum friseur und
laufe wek mit für euch bezahlen muss
echt warm hier drin sie auch
klimaanlagen geben könnte wenn ich mein
ticket bezahlen
das ist doch jetzt bestimmt ein
kontrolleur so sehen jedoch immer aus
wie der nette mann von nebenan
gleich spricht er mich an und mich nach
meinem ticket fragen was ich nicht habe
und dann muss ich eine richtig gute
erklärung haben vielleicht so etwas wie
der ticketautomat gängig oder etwas
romantischeres vielleicht weil ich auch
ich wollte nur die uhrzeit wissen